The topic of my prejuda
is Islam
the path to happiness.
Islam comes from the root word salam
which means peace. It's also derived
from the Arabic word silm which means to
submit your will to Allah subhananaa
tala. And in short Islam means peace
acquired by submitting your will to
Allah subhananaa tala to almighty God.
Happiness according to the Webster
dictionary means
a state of well-being and contentment,
pleasure
and satisfying experience.
But the psychologists they have a
different definition of happiness. They
say happiness is a continuous feeling of
enjoyment, delight, satisfaction and
generosity
along with contentment of one's own self
and
the future blissful destiny.
That mean for psychologists happiness is
a continuous state not only of present
even of future.
Their happiness can be categorized into
three different types.
The first category is false happiness.
This false happiness is very short-lived
and some people may consume drugs,
alcohol, intoxicants
which gives them a delusion of
happiness.
But this delusion of happiness is
short-lived. The moment the intoxication
waines, the effect of the drug waines,
happiness also disappears. And then
there is misery.
Due to which the person has more drugs,
more alcohol,
he then becomes a drug addict.
And
this happiness is false happiness. The
first category which is short-lived and
only a delusion. The second category of
happiness is the temporary happiness
which is achieved after achieving a
goal. You may want to come first in the
classroom. You may want to come first in
a race or want to win a boxing match or
you want to be a very rich man or you
want to become a doctor. You have a
goal. When you achieve the goal, you
feel happy. But this happiness is also
short-lived. But it is not as damaging
as the first category. Once you achieve
the goal then again your state of
happiness disappears. So the second
category which is called as temporary
happiness is
only short-lived when you achieve a
particular target. You have a particular
goal you have whether you want to be a
rich man or you want to become a
minister. Whatever goal you have once
you achieve you get happiness for a
short time after that it vanishes. The
third category of happiness is the true
happiness. This happiness according to
psychologist
and according to scientist they say this
happiness is a continuous happiness and
a feeling of enjoyment,
delight
and generosity.
It's a continuous feeling. It's not
temporary. And this continuous feeling
of happiness is unlike the first two
category. It can only be achieved on a
belief.
If you have faith and if you analyze the
various types of belief that you have in
today's world, the only ultimate to
happiness can be achieved by following
Islam.
The religion of peace, the religion of
submitting your will to your Allah
subhanaa tala. If you have faith and if
you analyze the various types of belief
that you have in today's world, the only
ultimate to happiness can be achieved by
following Islam.
The religion of peace, the religion of
submitting your will to your creat Allah
subhanaa tala.